faking and with little else to do this
is what almost 33 degree heat looks like
after three months in lockdown
Bournemouth councils worst nightmare a
major incident declared after thousands
of people defied advice to stay away
illegal parking 33 tons of waste drunken
fights and gridlock on the roads these
are incredible numbers I mean beautiful
Dorset is a beautiful place to go but
half a million people its product of a
perfect storm really and some of the the
actions that we've seen very selfish
behavior that we've seen on Bournemouth
Beach is not what Britain should be
about in this enduring emergency further
down the coast in Brighton Marshalls
were on standby ready to shut down the
beach should similar crowds occur
impatient for the next phase of lockdown
easing social distancing rules seem to
be going out the window
could this undo everything we've
achieved in lockdown The Closer people
are together the greater the risk is
that the virus will spread and we've
seen a resurgence of koban 19 in
countries around the world that thought
they got on top of it so this is a real
course of concern hot and with nowhere
to go this is what you get government
plans to temporarily change licensing
laws so that more restaurants pubs and
cafes will be able to serve food and
drink outside from July the fourth are
certainly welcome of course that only
works at venues that have the space to
extend out into on a residential street
with little room outside the best bright
and beer dispensary can hope for is that
its customers still want to take aways
even on the 4th of July of people to let
be let in to the pub many tiny we don't
have a massive capacity so it doesn't
make sense rust here too to start up
again it's just not it's not feasible
really it's not a good business model
for us at the end of the day it's all
about keeping everyone safe that's what
we want nobody wants to be the first pub
to to have to deal with like a big
outbreak you know
without foreign holidays and with
temperatures higher than Ibiza as
tempting as it might be to head to the
coast to get our feet wet as genuine
concern scenes like these could cause a
second wave of outbreaks Keita Spencer
Sky News